there's sometimes a sort of silly view
from climate science deniers who say hey
even if the world is warming it's kind
of a nice thing right who doesn't like
warm days and more of the world will
have them if the planet warms up a
little bit right now about 30 percent of
the world's population is at risk of
death from extreme heat on at least 20
days of the year and of course that's up
from the number of days in past years
and there's a new study published in
Nature climate change that says by the
year 2100 we could see 48 to 74 percent
of the world's population exposed to
potentially deadly extreme heat on at
least 20 days each year this will be in
part because of weather becoming more
and more dangerous as a result of
climate change and 48 to 74 48 is the
best-case scenario and that would be if
the world drastically cuts greenhouse
gas emissions and that would mean that
only half of the world would be at risk
of heat death for roughly 20 days per
year the 74 percent figure the high part
of that range would be if emissions
continue to rise at their current pace
and forget about if MIFF emissions
accelerate which they could then you
could see even worse numbers altogether
and the study looked at all available
data on past heat related deaths to
figure out well what's the threshold
between what we consider deadly heat and
non deadly heat and humidity and
humidity is a factor here as well
because the body is less able to sweat
in higher humidity which is sort of our
primary way the primary way that the
body is able to release heat and
obviously if our body temperature goes
up too much organs can start to
malfunction all sorts of other bad
things complicated things to quote
Donald Trump start to happen so if we
stay on the road that we're on about
three-quarters of the world's population
would be at risk of dying from heat for
about three weeks per year even if we
make some big changes about half of the
world's population will still be in that
situation and scientists say and you
don't really need to be a scientist to
figure this out the elderly are at
particularly high risk on these really
hot days and as logic would tell you
people living closer to the equator
be most affected in the future they're
already the most affected by this and
unfortunately those are also some of the
poorest parts of the world and least
well-equipped to deal with medical
problems this includes Africa this
includes in Latin America around the
equator it includes South Asia and as
always every time you see a report like
this you need to look at it with a
critical eye right the population is
expected to increase more in hotter
areas than in colder areas so climate
change aside that's going to put more
people in these areas that are at risk
people also could start dying from cold
exposure and or in other words we have
people that already die from cold
exposure which if it gets a little
warmer in those parts of the world you
might see fewer people die from cold
exposure whereas people in other areas
are more likely to die from heat
exposure but if and when things get
worse you won't even have to be close to
the equator because the region in which
this will be a problem is going to grow
as the climate warms I just think a lot
of people look at this and say well I'm
not even going to be alive in the year
2100 you know what does it matter but if
you love your kids and your grandkids
you should care about this unfortunately
we have so many people in America too
who just think that the rapture is going
to happen before then so what does it
matter I've interviewed some of those
people yeah it's a it's hard to have a
serious conversation with them and then
some people like to make this argument
Pat of like oh well but it was really
cold today right the get was Minnesota
in January obvious varies weather
obviously it was really cold even our
current president has used that
logically fallacious argument before to
try to ignore climate science he once
tweeted a big part of the country even
the southern states is under massive
attack from snow and freezing cold
global warming anyone and this isn't
even some hypothetical thing where now
no-one dies of heat we already have
people dying of heat all scientists are
telling us is the number of people who
are going to be at risk of heat death is
going to go up and I remember that
Bernie Sanders was laughed at for saying
that the biggest threat to our foreign
policy is climate change right it seems
so incredibly obvious because as
resources get more scarce and some of
those resources are essential to our
life and our
existence people are going to have to
fight for them if you can't get water
and food well water is a big one that
we've talked about and I've done a
couple interviews with David Zetland
which are really interesting and I
encourage you to check out on YouTube